what's going on guys this isn't a video
i was expecting to make today but a few
hours ago we got new information
regarding the release date for the
second half of attack on titan the final
season as well as a message from the
director of the series if you're
watching this then i'm sure you already
know the first half of the final season
finished in march 2021 with porco reiner
and the rest of the marine forces
beginning their attack on shiganjina the
official website for the attack on titan
anime now says that the series will
continue in january 2022 and the title
for the newest episode in january will
be condemnation it says here that before
the episode is broadcast in japan there
will be a special omnibus that looks
back on the progress of the anime so far
and an original animation that talks
from the perspective of levi annie
mikasa and other characters as well
whether that original animation will be
uploaded to crunchyroll is not confirmed
but one thing we now know for sure is
that january is the month where
everything will start again and
regarding the special omnibus i just
imagine that would be like an updated
version of attack on titan chronicle
as you can see here there is not a
specific date as to when the anime will
return
but you know during the first half of
the season episodes usually aired in
japan on on a monday quite early on
mondays and then they appear on
crunchyroll a few hours after that so
for me personally living in europe that
was usually a sunday evening it would be
uploaded in the press release they don't
say that schedule will change in any way
um so if we look at the calendar here i
imagine for most of you watching this
video as well they normally came out on
sundays so uh yeah either the second the
9th the 16th the 23rd or the 30th of the
month although i hope it's not that one
but one of these dates will likely be
when the anime will return for us
anyway moving on on the website we also
have comments from the director of the
final season as well as the voice actor
for erin and so looking at the
director's statement first he says thank
you for waiting the final season part
two will start in january next year from
the large-scale battle in shiganshina to
the origin story of the titans we are
finally approaching the climax we are
also taking on many new challenges in
terms of images and how that scene will
be visualized please look forward to it
so that comment there about the uh the
challenges of the new images if you're a
mangrove you know this but the attacker
type of manga in terms of art it gets
very complex towards the end there are
certain things that will be very
difficult to animate and i think that's
what the director is referring to
because uh yeah things will get way more
difficult to animate than they did in
the first half of the season so this is
just me speculating but i imagine the
second part will be quite cgi heavy
because if we look back in the first
half there was a decent amount of cgi
even though um it wasn't nearly as
complex as what they need to animate for
the second half so again there's gonna
be a lot of cgi but i think it's
practical i definitely prefer it when
the titans are in 2d but i also
understand why sometimes it needs to be
3d and all that because yeah this stuff
is just it's not easy it's not easy at
all so uh i don't envy the people that
do have to animate this but i'm sure
when it comes out next year it would be
great
for the voice actor for aaron he only
made one statement and that was if you
don't fight you can't win and yeah that
was it short and sweet nice and simple
and uh yeah yeah so looking forward to
it january 2022 is when the uh the
second half of the season resumes and if
you haven't seen already then do be sure
to check out my reviews for the first
half of the season for pretty much every
episode except the very first one i
broke it down you know referenced the
manga but i didn't give away any
spoilers or anything so so if you want
to check it out the link should be on
screen if you want to see those episode
reviews don't forget to hit that sub
button and drop a like if you like this
video and until the next one peace out